hey I was gonna breasts - welcome to the
final part of stray cat crossing we're
about to finish this amazing game I
can't wait to see what the ending is
gonna be there everyone leave now yeah
they did oh oh they left me the cake
tasted licking dries okay I'll be taking
that
let's see if the toys are still down
here
a musical monkey why does it look so
frightened nothing changed here did it
okay let's go back alright what items do
we have are the key cake penny and film
reel I think I know what we're missing
be ah okay you can go in here what is
this
gear is Lisa
oh the clock doesn't work anymore it's
been frozen for 15 years cat do you
remember yet no here let's try again
what what this happened
everything reset no no not again okay we
need to redo it three times to get the
three pennies let's do it again but I
don't have the key this time
Oh God that means I have to redo
everything doesn't it so now we have the
key we can go in get the coin so now we
can buy popcorn for whatever that's
worth
great and we need to get in how do you
get in again Oh God okay the place over
we need to get some popcorn to this
[ __ ]
yes I got your popcorn what does that
give me a woodblock as thanks the [ __ ]
are we gonna do with a woodblock
we can give him the woodblock holy [ __ ]
I just guessed
we got a toy soldier goddammit another
plays starting alright so we're gonna
give him the toy soldier cool you're
welcome
then again we need to get into the play
by giving him the rose
there it is thirst rose all right let's
see if he's happy now he's much better
behaved now thank you here maybe he
won't need this anymore
so that son of a [ __ ] had the scrip the
little one found that on the floor maybe
you will find it useful yes I will thank
you now we can finish the play what's
your save and let's finish it alright so
I'm giving him the script that's the
script you found it thank you now we can
finish the play you're not half bad my
brothers might be rude to you but they
don't hate you they don't eat I know
I'll give you something cool after the
play the play is about to begin please
make your way to their seat okay here we
go
mommy's stop reading to me at bedtime
Benjamin stop giving me presents and so
and so Kat decides that night you
decided to run away
here we are this is Kat she has run away
from home she is very sad you can tell
I'm sad Seb slow down hey Kat do you
still remember me
are we playing as a little cat now hey
that's our scarf sit slow down mark mark
hey what say that girl
um hello uh hello
I like your dog this is Sebastian
mom he helps me see you can't see what's
wrong with your eyes
they got burned up hate when that
happens
it's when I look at too much Pompey but
dr5 says he can fix them you know dr.
Phibes - um can I take a picture of me
catch where's catch Benjamin you're
driving too fast
cat where's cat I take pictures of
everything
so I can't can't see again I'll know all
the places I've been I wanna see we're
looking for this cat Oh
these pictures are all blurry what it's
because you keep moving back and forth
here hold still
now take a picture now it's not very Wow
Thank You Martha
what is going on cippec Seb wants to
know your name my name my name is Kat
this is so confusing
nice to meet you Kat my name is what we
should head back it's late shouldn't you
go home - I ran away from home
alright mommy and daddy they don't want
me anymore
they could be looking for you they must
be worried
is that the cat oh my god it's cat
double cat cat ception look a cat a cat
where they're crossing the street a
straight cat just like you
just like me
Oh picture hold still
maybe it's lonely too just like me hmm
here kitty-kitty
what's wrong are you lost
it's pretty late do you know where your
house is
I can take you home if you want mosh cat
at Oh God a car cat no hey cat do you
still remember me
you came back I knew you would
that's why I waited that's why why we
all waited thanks Ken thanks for coming
back what what hey the show's over
thanks for finding the script for us now
we can win all the awards
yeah I think you should have this oh we
got the gear now bye-bye
okay it's time it's time to talk to
we don't have the key do we how we don't
need it good this should be it
grandfather clock but it isn't moving
yes the gear fits perfectly it wasn't
your fault can we don't blame you 10
there are millions of daddies in the
world millions of girls get to have a
daddy's lap but only little cat gets to
have Benjamin's luck that's why I want
you to call me Benjamin
okay you remember now don't you dad
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I wasn't
your fault
but it was my fault my phone my phone my
phone I thought I ran away but I
shouldn't have I'm sorry I'm sorry I ran
away you couldn't have known but I did
now I knew it would happen I knew they
would come find me come find me
come find me they loved you very much
very much that's not true they hate me
hate me hate me hate me they don't hate
you
I've talked to them all of them the
twins
mom dad even the boy with the camera
they'll forgive you as long as you don't
forget them they'll forgive you as long
as you don't forget them yeah
you fix the clock time isn't frozen
anymore this house it's only a memory
it's fading you need to leave follow me
please
oh boy hurry this way
they have the twins
hurry almost there
you
I am a memory - cat I know it's hard but
don't forget me again ok promise promise
wait I never knew your name my name my
name is
Sebastian
all right
that was stray cat crossing really
really wonderful RPG horror why do I
keep saying horror RPG maker game uh
it's really nice to see I want to see
more games like these cuz I don't know
all those a band which house they're so
good but it's like it's only those and
you need more and I really feel like
this one is up up with those it's really
high quality and really really enjoyed
playing it I need to get the soundtrack
it's [ __ ] amazing such a nice game
I'm so glad I found it and I'm so glad I
got two experiences together with you
bros thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I did if
you enjoyed it please leave a like share
it with your friends and write a song
holy [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] way to end it oh my god
gave me chills ok see you next stairs
Prez say awesome
you